I'm curious what kind of advice you
would give to people right now who are
looking at the world around them and
facing layoffs and facing still supply
chain shocks and questions in China of
how to deal with pandemics pandemic
potentially raging as a manager you're
dealing with all of this uncertainty
what do you how do you manage through
that
it's it's the same everything that
happens happens because of causes that
make it happen
and so if you step back and you look at
the patterns of things happening like uh
like a doctor who you know has a long
career and sees many cases you you begin
to understand the patterns and you
understand the cause effect
relationships so uh I mean the answer to
that is it's just a function of how the
machine works you know the cause affect
relationships that keep having these
dominoes happen and if you step back and
you look at that how does reality work
and particularly your reality so my
realities are the markets the economy
how does that work understand those
cause or relationships understand the
Timeless and Universal principles